[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
hey guys and welcome to GameSpot live
I'm chastity today we're presented by
oculus and we're gonna leave our reality
and enter a virtual one I'm with Ben
djenka today and we're gonna play three
VR games on the oculus rift there's Ben
he's in virtual reality he has already
left us and we're gonna play I expect
you to die super hot and robo recall so
thirty minutes of each and we're gonna
hang out in chat on youtube youtube.com
slash GameSpot until 1:00 p.m. so join
me talk about all your favorite VR games
talk about the best VR games of the year
what your favorite oculus games are and
let's jump into I expect you to die
first
alright Ben you've played this game
before I have played this game before
and tell us what's going on tell us what
this game is so the whole setup for this
game is it's basically a training thing
for being a spy are you a good spy or
are you a novice spy what's going on
celebrating and you you get put on
different missions to basically learn
what it's like to be a spy yep so the
first one we get to do we're gonna get
briefed on we're locked inside of a car
on a plane cause and we've got to find a
way to break out there's no poison gas
and all sorts of spy things happen
alright let's go so we get to drive a
car out of a plane alright wait hold on
we gotta fix Ben's Micah's we can barely
hear but just keep doing what you're
doing I'll just describe what you're
doing so you're in you're in a car right
now Ben's Mike's getting adjusted
alright
well you're in virtual reality you don't
need to see us so what's it what's going
on in this car is that champagne a nice
jump on ya
alright little technical difficulties
with the mic but ya know just just do
stuff yeah just pour yourself some nice
champagne yeah mm-hmm have a sip Liv
that spike just there was some a nice
champagne shower
he just gave himself a champagne shower
you don't need that anymore
oh hey money let's just go can you just
take that and leave I think the key here
is to just take the money and go oh
there's a key all right yeah uh what
we've got to figure out is lean over
here the glove box crime said don't
drink and drive by the way yeah no
problem we just poured it over our heads
fine nobody's drunk yeah we're fine Wow
we keep keep that stack though you have
a lot of money yeah there's a lot going
on what's that this guy get instructions
got instructions how does it point
there's a parachute in our car so we're
probably gonna tip you so regular car
that's a spy car exactly so I got here
this is the mm-hmm sweets is ever okay
all right so what do you see a
screwdriver in the car don't think
there's one right how do you get it
there so we probably need to turn on the
car huh we have to open up the window
carefully though because there's gas out
there this little guy who did that looks
paint nope nope wait what is that
excuse me okay it was a laser wait
that's always more fun that's definitely
a laser that's just a normal thing my
car does all right cool you'll need to
cut those why I don't think this is safe
to drive where's that knife at we're
gonna go is it in the glove box
oh that's his money don't do that why
did you oh my god that wasn't how you
solved that and now we know that we need
to take we need to keep track of that no
it's okay so you start anew
you know there's a cool game is this is
I expect you to die we're playing on the
oculus rift this is actually on sale
right now yeah all right you'll need to
cut those wide that's nice right are you
any wire that's risky is there
instructions are you okay there's
probably a manual so many times will you
die hey chat take a guess on how many
times he'll die on this car it's
probably the view you don't win anything
but my respect
nice good dodge good dodge yes okay okay
good and green what's next now we gotta
unscrew these screws huh here you are
this cars very just kill you got these
uh there we go okay weapons are online
taking bets on how many times you die
ten years in 242 no no oh my god oh my
god what's happening I just looks away
to look at chat what are you okay Wow
what's what's this oh you know what I
think
uh-huh I think we should take this
dynamite dad you bet 69 that's how many
times you're gonna drive a car Oh Tommy
said I'm 13
mission complete mission complete we did
it yeah no run on the next one oh right
the next one asks what's next in spy in
life throw that out the window yeah we
don't need that we don't need that
anymore we can just get rid of that is
it cigar time do we celebrate oh it's
you soon to celebrate well pop in our
our next mission listen to the briefing
all right well for those of you that
gets his 69 times he did not die 69
times in that car undercover undercover
all right yeah take take a nice
celebratory smoke what you got welcome
agent things are not always as they seem
oh this is the super virus one okay okay
how many times have you played this game
uh a few all right not since the most
recent update which added a whole bunch
of stuff but interesting enough to know
that I really like it's a cool idea for
a puzzle game it is a very cool idea I'm
into it I'm just gonna hit go take us in
take us into spy land
okay here we are where are we so we're
on skyscraper and we have to find a way
to break this glass break mess with
these deadly supervirus ins yes now I
understand the title of this game you
through making an anti bar they do
expect you to die we can clean it
uh-huh no do you wanna is that like
filled with acid like how are you know
they don't think that I'm like doing
something bad ah we really do is Oh
a gun there it is nobody heard that no
it's fine everything's okay is that
coffee huh maybe can you drink it it's
spy coffee drink it you pour it on your
head again yeah that's cool that's
sometimes you gotta yeah I think that's
the theme here I think in every
situation you pour the drink on your
head we got a note here attention yeah
yeah that's fair that's cool
yeah good get rid of that yeah Oh gray
fox said great work been also hola
chasity hola como estas so we are
telepathy we can see if there are lasers
in here so that's gonna make moving
things around much more difficult uh-huh
oh no lasers how are you doing this
telepathy every spot has telepathy
that's important facts how did you get
to levity did you have to have telepathy
to become a spy or what become a spy and
then they gave you telepathy there's
some sort of probably brainwashing thing
that happens I'm sure spy stuffs wild
that's pretty neat so this one I know
this one's got like a lot of ways to
kind of do it I'm trying to remember
exactly how to make it happen there's so
many options here there's so many things
that you can pull and that's with Shh
what could it be
[Music]
what's in there bring it to us
Oh we'll just trip the laser oh wow see
almost laser and now we're going to
definitely die that's right there no
that's not useful at all no it's got
some VR games sent today what'd you get
good oh yeah tell us what you got tell
us about your VR games everyone knows
about your favorite VR games I don't
know those don't go down we believe so
accessing the windows a better spot tell
us how to be good spies cuz your boy is
very good at shooting out the window and
that's probably not the best way to do
it I mean that seems like your only
option right now are it or is that what
set off the lasers or where the lasers
already on I grabbed one of those things
cool so that's good mm-hmm put that
safely over here yes very carefully okay
so you can also trip lasers with bullets
so that's good for science for science
of course I like the way you think all
right
tickets back in so I'm wondering if I
can actually grab all those are crimes
that use the spray can you spray the
room going to your body
what's your body where is it uh it's a
good question you're just hands it's
kind of just an important part for being
a spy no that's very no one's gonna see
you because you don't have a body
no it means a good spy joint okay so
that's all three of those oh no they
broke probably not good we don't want
that to happen okay I'll spray to locate
lasers so we gotta be sure that's good
laser manufacturers just stop so open
that up to just because
sure why not just open things so we got
going on over here got some dangerous
biohazard stuff uh-huh
know what's going on over here but we're
gonna try to pull it out hmm
okay so we got this huh
that that looks like an important thing
I like bring this to me
uh-huh this is the note yeah it wasn't
that useful right not sure that looks
like a thing that we could probably how
many times have we died so far like
three a few sorry
shoot that take another bet guys in the
chat how many times are we dying in
laser room 20 edwards ask how much is
this thing well on Steam it's on sale
for 50% off $12.49 to buy eggs I expect
you to die there's a deal there's the
lasers got more lasers going on well
what are in these containers
Oh said the sheet and the locker is
useful for those test tube things okay
so we do need to get the stuff in the
locker a sheet in the locker hmm is that
the one that has the little sheet in it
great that's the sheet okay so I'm gonna
try to slowly bring this out
it's like I get burned up in a laser I'm
trying not to hit a laser try to like
this is that's that's je je demande said
you have to unlock the locker to get the
ID card to swipe the red beaming lights
all right
hot tip trying to find the ID card
unlock the money money money it's
everyone is money always this my oh that
looks like it looks like a card
oh we died from gas or something we're
good yeah all right so grab this do this
Tommy had a lot of fish here we are
extreme attano Corvo we're playing I
expect you to die we're playing this for
another 12 minutes or so and then we're
gonna play two more games on the oculus
rift today replace super hot and robo
recall hello all right there it is let's
go some try to just ID card swipe the
red beetle yeah I like it
okay disclosure agent I don't really
know how to make an anti-virus this
Shawn in HR says you tested well in
chemistry all right what now give it a
go so millions of lives don't blow
yourself up so the guy was like I'll
walk you through making the Santa
enviros don't even worry about it and
then I get everything else up he's like
actually there's probably something
around here that has it must be
something else
letter has the letter has the three
tubes on it
okay so we need to get that's dorcette
so the biggest thing going on right now
is mm-hmm
it's a very foggy in my headset oh boy
so I'm do you want to take off the
headset really quickly and put it back
on how we're good okay bill it'll go
away in a sec probably can you give me
this is it is this the one we're talking
about kind of colors going on is this
what the letter has the three tubes on
it is what the oil said and if you
combine them on the test tube rack then
you get a special antivirus oh oh so we
just turn up maybe yellow combine them
on the test tube rack
this isn't yellow what do we mix to get
yellow of course nothing else is there
is there a yellow in the room that I
can't see let's put that there anyway so
[Music]
I think that's that's the key I think
it's the purple yellow red situation yes
so I probably need to doesn't go there
if anyone's good at science and also
keep walking me through it I'm into it
yeah cuz I probably have to combine more
of these unless maybe this will get me
more the same colors or it yeah yeah
so we need probably more only seeing the
Doyle said the yellow is on the left is
and you use the other sheet to make her
Ossa faceted one two mythmobile chain
okay so it's over over here then I need
to make acid
which is probably something else around
here that'll tell me how to do that
what's the combination for acid though
well you know we can probably mess
around with it it's button blue and
green is yellow that was not right Gog
grouping there that's fine we chemistry
involved we know Zola wants revenge get
into that lab an ID card antivirus I
don't think this is the ID card
no but it's cool though it's in the
other locker yeah Lord swirling to me
all going to play super hot BR that's
the next game that we're playing in
about eight minutes
thank you switch over to that you're
playing super hot right after this and
I'll be playing that so we'll get some
more cool action stuff going on real
soon and then Robo recall after that all
right
just said how would you normally figure
this out trial in there yeah pretty much
making us so it's there's there's
probably stuff hidden around somewhere
that's like oh these things means
together and don't logo so far what if
it's not that that's steamy oh boy okay
Jonah said there are colored levers on
the left we can get the acid switch the
ones you need switch the ones you need
and flip the lever and you should get
the colors you need for so it's just
this stuff on the left oh I didn't even
see these okay yeah so those those
levers right there on the left side so
you find a way to get rid of that though
uh so they need to like there's a sheet
with recipes you need to find them yeah
that's crime this what we're looking at
grey fox that the first piece of paper
before the ID has the color combinations
okay the one that we got before this so
this is yeah what are we looking at here
so we don't want the explodey one the
acid one looks like it's the top one so
Kyle said try purple and blue blue is
what we're thinking
it's what Kyle thinking it looks like it
says the levers a purple move for the
lever I think I can't even mess with
that yet though Oh even see the purple
it's purple and I or no I need to move
the other ones off Oh interesting
and then maybe doing that changes it
there we go now we got green green okay
cool which is good let's get rid of this
stuff in it and yellow is it's green and
red is that what's going on like a
formula sheet uh no not really not sure
yeah I am also not sure I can't read I
hit it who knows we got it
don't forget the table it's not it at
all what take forgot that we knows all
extreme I was too hasty so give it a go
just a green blue don't blow yourself up
so green green blue that makes a lot of
sense
so let's this do that green is over
there blue was over there that good
stuff cool okay so this is actually I
just realizes if we can just speed run
it will be fun totally just you've got
four minutes to figure out this room and
then we're switching games really know
how to make an anti-virus okay so we've
got that again
crime said find the clues first got this
again huh
and all that's just money in there right
Doyle said the table is on the right
back wall above the box has the color
and symbols on it
over here this thing this is a clipboard
oh that's oh yeah oh yeah no yes you
above that box that kind of to the left
there's a thing on the wall you see it
there's like a picture Oh picture frame
this thing yeah yeah this thing okay
yeah there yeah all right so now can we
can read we can see we need to put this
over here for now this over here table
of synthetic elements okay snow we've
got everything laid out so we need just
Shh what are we looking at walk me
through this look at the table so
there's the yellow there it goes there
yeah I still don't know nn okay so then
look at that picture of the kids drawing
Oh so still think it's it's purple
yellow and red that we need yeah that's
that holds true I mean a way to make got
purple Christic combined green and blue
to make yellow so green and blue
buddhist blew up yeah how do we combine
them but not in there is it we're just
space where your insists it's green and
red to make yellow I think we did green
and red originally okay but I'll try to
get just oh boy because oh boy
it's definitely gonna blow up oh boy do
we not combine it there might not yeah I
that's the only place I can find a
combine because it tells you what
explodes on the other piece of paper
[Music]
you're just tuning in this is Ben's
maybe final attempt to figure out this
room and I expect you to die this is an
oculus game that we're playing Roger
we're playing to four games on the
oculus rift today we're gonna play
superhot give it a go save millions of
lives don't blow yourself up surprise no
one's up what colors actually had up to
make it I'm pretty sure we already got
it just something else that we're
missing crime said the shape with the
recipe follow it you need acid okay
money
alright so acid is the top one so we
need GI a R&Y sweet blue they are screen
cool and then why is red red all right
let me add that together and that should
get us the acid so we can break that
okay cool cool that's good now we're now
we're cooking alright agent you've been
spotted quick naturally alright and then
you can turn the villas the window
washer routine okay there think so right
yeah there there we go now we have
yellow knowledge how we're doing it hey
we need yellow purple
where'd the here does yours what we own
purple yellow red I'm just do it in the
right order
yeah altogether good call
purple orchid gets yellow red okay do it
oh hello progress very nice now do I
like like put it over in there is that
is that what we're doing try it ship it
hit the button for it is it good that
work well movin and shakin is that good
what is happening I think this is okay
now what happened all right so that arm
just came in that's moving
Princeton now the hardest part may be oh
great great
so check what happens now mulches with
virus millions will die ok lies that
virus now neutralise it neutral oh boy I
have to shoot the rocket how Oh
blam-blam-blam- get it no no throw it in
want you to actually probably make
explosives oh yeah
it's n N and G I so that's make it
happen yellow and green okay that's not
yellow yellow
this is actually gonna ship it out for
me l said pull the metal sheets and
there's a thing inside
did we need the guns yo really explicit
blue give me another one
I didn't toss it hard enough throw the
antivirus well that's just gonna make
the antivirus together yeah
making antivirus so it's purple purple
yellowing right
cool
you hear me a lot of time to do this
yeah well I mean we're three minutes
over but I want you to finish this
because you didn't die hmm
we made so much progress is that it not
oh no what happened
yeah football yellow need to make more
acid formula and you need to make an
explosive formula to open up the bomb
and then put it inside your antivirus so
I've got a hole that I can see it but I
put it in there and it just blew up
since we for it to come back around
maybe drop it
[Music]
where does it go does it like need to
break this is difficult this game is I
expect you to die
it's very properly titled good maybe for
the chains acid for the chains is yeah
we'll do that acid was chair and why
which is let's do the chart away you
through the church
do we do remember what it was no where's
the church it's behind me off the side
well that's where this is gonna sit oh
boy
[Laughter]
and you're gonna come in all right yeah
that's it we're gonna try a different
game now we're gonna mix it up yes we
are gonna mix it up okay so next we are
going to play some superhot and followed
by Robo recall so Ben's gonna do Robo
recall at the end I'm gonna play super
hot right now so I'm gonna go switch
with him so if you want to get out of
that headset Ben I'm doing this much
over so we are playing oculus rift games
today presented by oculus I'm chasity
that was Ben playing I expect you to die
that game is on sale right now on Steam
if you want to get that and do a better
job than we did we couldn't figure out
that room but we tried our best
we really did all right how you doing
Ben you're alive
hi nice join us in the chat we're on
YouTube right now youtube.com slash
GameSpot and we are talking about VR in
the chat and they're giving us all these
tips and helping us out so that's really
kind of you I'm gonna go get into
virtual reality can you switch over to
super hot for me Wow
okay ready to do the stuff yeah well I'm
gonna go into virtual reality so join me
would you like to take over that should
make sure I hand this off to you first
thank you okay let me adjust this super
ahh is really rad though very key with
me like I set this down or I'm just
gonna give this a wipe yeah that's a
very good cause little sweaty in here
whoo hey you doing uh doing uh I still
like that game even though I'm not that
great at it I think I need headphones
for smoke uh I mean unless you want to
hear though the cool sounds or anything
but gotcha
here we go all right
oh boy where do I stand let me get in my
spot first moving the position yeah all
right yeah just my here's a left hand
first there you go thank you thank you
okay figure this I'm in the game yeah
okay this is super hot y'all I've only
played a very little bit of this but
it's really cool
we're playing an oculus oh boy so when
you move when you don't move the game
doesn't continue hello everyone
wow it's me fresh off VR how are you
doing I hope you're super hot dude grab
oh she's doing BAM I'm doing it she's
I'm doing it y'all all right if you got
stools yours let me know if I'm just
gonna tread it get as John wick as
possible you know just gonna feel like
it's gotta let out question rule 2018 oh
my god Oh
bullets I'm very ready to take this word
a lot when you're not like able to talk
to anyone lawyer on a street chassis is
having a very good time sorry she's
about to punch Erik pain in the head I'm
gonna give you a live play-by-play on
what's happening right now in the studio
you because it's real wild
look at him fall that's art this is a
beautiful game by the way feeling VR
Grogg uh not too bad to be honest that
game was was
for $10 anticipating to read for answer
okay that makes the most sense calculate
your face so a game that is I can
actually say about trial and error
definitely super hot cuz you get to
secure and run for these things
Jerry hotline Miami s and that you're
you're like going back and forth a whole
bunch yeah it's it's up now we had some
weird technical stuff I didn't even look
at it like a like a real chump but we've
got it we're getting it it's here for
you punch take you can't punch hey
oh did you actually shoulder it's a good
time to mention if you're not planning
on playing VR around your friends
definitely be aware where you are don't
punch your best friend Eric Tay yep your
chassis is very intense she's she was
messing around a bit yesterday to get
ready and she was all over it was yeah
there's some wild business going on
you're not supposed to move so much in
superhot hey you know that's this is
hard moon you've got a you've got to
constantly move to the time constant it
moves it's like it's actually happening
so when I stay still they don't move
yeah time moves when you move so you can
kind of like ooh he's messing with you
the one straight boy that one guy
thought he was smart Tommy says I've got
to go study sorry bye guys really
enjoyed the stream thank you my gun my
gun just shattered because I dropped it
that's needy I'm immense strength of
superhot of the gun shattering power of
you the player oh damn that was great
Fox says that you're basically neo from
the matrix yeah that's what I'm feeling
and I'm really into that the game you
played Ben was actually really hard you
have to play a few times to know it's
you exactly it's it's more puzzling and
if I was it I think the VR game that I
probably played the most is Bravo Rico
which is the one we're playing after err
super hot and it's really nice because
it is actually a game that you get for
free with your touch yeah it's it's
probably the best example I've probably
played and it feels like there's a lot
of like oh no what am I gonna do yeah
there you go
poor man's leg shatters because you
threw an ashtray at it I know what is
that about what kind of bad trades are
these powerful ashtrays
hey Jerry how are you doing welcome
where am i where am i back here again
alright that guy's gonna die a million
times he's the one to break it all in
you got you got the like no he got that
one here so it's actually really really
interesting I was mentioning it a bit
yesterday when we were practicing but uh
some of these levels in superhot are
actually still like interconnected and
people who are like really practiced up
at will do things like go grab the gun
out of the suitcase and then they'll
grab the other one and they'll grab the
second gun and toss it like up into the
air I maybe just hit my mic I apologize
uh and it will actually fly to the place
where they're about to teleport too slow
they're able to like grab it out of the
air in the next scene which is really
kind of cool
robell recall is incredible you can mob
that game with new guns and enemies it
is a really cool platform for mods - I
haven't dug too much anyone but I've
seen some of them but I just love like
the systems in that game attitude I like
the fact that you you toss your guns
away every time you're done with them
instead of reloading them because what's
more cool than just like tossing
something off to the side when you're
done with it and being able to pull
another one off of your head Arizona
sunshine also a very cool one I like
that you can play co-op stuff haven't
played as much of it but what it did I
enjoy other any sports games for VR I
feel like there are more like like table
tennis or like not so much like
basketball or soccer or anything like
that you can find like like a gold
shootout or maybe like that
a free-throw contest kind of deal but a
lot of like the the ping-pong ones are
pretty cool
I'm played to many ups definitely check
it out though especially now if you're
thinking about getting into VR it's a
pretty good time it's a you got the
Steam sale going on there are a lot of
good deals usually going on with like
got the regular VR headsets because
there's putting out new hardware oh
boxing is a very good one there are a
lot of very good boxers one of my
favourite VR games is sound boxing which
if you like the idea of like a musical
game it only cost like five dollars but
basically the whole idea of it is you
punch along to any video you can find on
YouTube and then people can upload their
own charts for punching through stuff
and people have like ah here's my
aerobic workout for sandstorm by darude
and you can like have this
high-intensity wasps or you can have
someone who like does the actual dance
moves - hotline bling - the hotline
bling music video and it's got a really
cool variety of just cool things you do
you can punch along your favorite vine
compilations the Creed boxing game is
sport
I haven't played it I we do have a copy
sitting around the speed zone and I keep
seeing it but I'd even think about the
Creed boxing game the teleport future
that's here haven't I haven't seen it
yet myself but it's helpful feed you
know the recall makes you feel like the
flash does it behind everywhere it's
true you can even nothing personal kid
every single robot that's what a few
games evolved into a movie like ready
player one that'd be awesome
to have my gun it's true I mean all it
takes us for what like I came like
Second Life to kind of take off and the
name of the game yeah rule the credits
we've got it credits football of year
would probably cause a lot of motion
sickness and broken furniture very
traveling can we see beats a room for
the streamlines so we were thinking
about doing beat Sabre but we also want
to try to like highlight specific things
that like we we kind of enjoyed outside
of musical stuff also I'm not sure about
the copyright for it which could always
be a problem with streaming but Russell
sure beats Sabres very good time
three guys this is one of the ones I
think I first saw the person like throw
a weapon to themselves I'm like all that
that's crazy
oh yeah more guns perfect your football
you mean destroy your living room IRL
that's definitely it
surrounded Yanks alright alright so you
have people like coming in from all
sides down on the bottom or around you
yeah you got ninja stars yeah just as
soon as it happened you just like going
low that's a very safe maneuver has any
was played elder scrolls Skyrim VR I've
seen one of our wonderful producers John
Luke play it a bit he is having a pretty
good time I was having a fun time
watching him y'all yeah you start to
start to kind of feel it after a while
I mean I look so beautiful when I get
out of this video oh yeah I mean you saw
me when I came out I look like I just I
don't know ran like three miles and I
was playing a game where I was sitting
down yes
boxing martial arts them I feel like
like the ability to use your limbs cuz
you can also get leg trackers so you
could actually do like a proper karate
you really are asking if they found a
way to like trance translate throws it
something like that to feel like VR
isn't a good place to move forward and
do a lot of cool things crime also
prints out old chastity you shot a
bullet out of the air that was really
intense
come at me yeah yeah yeah that man's
head exploded also the feeling of
catching a gun it's a very you're not
I'm gonna be honest I kind of prefer
playing Skyrim normally it didn't look
like I'd want it Star beer or doesn't
look like a thing I want to spend like a
hundred and twenty hours running around
that's that's just me but it it also
would be kind of cool to walk around in
those places
have some technical problems on PC I
haven't played enough of them that's
definitely thing to keep those terms on
sale for 30 bucks it's the it's like the
whole game in VR from what I understand
so I mean if it works in it wrong do
some sweet dragon shouts oh that's
another good one gourds fantastic it's a
very good shout out jayvon so it's kind
of like this gladiatorial arena combat
game it's hyper stylized but you get to
like you get to get different weapons
and fight off a bunch of dudes and they
all have different armor configurations
you have to do different things it's
really good grey fox if they ever put a
yoke is a game in VR I will play it in
chesties going real hard perfect need to
bind aim controller this is pretty cool
I like the idea of also having their
physical peripherals in real life that
kind of simulate actually holding the
things that you're messing with that's
really tough so just as a reminder to if
if anything seems like it's kind of
intense you just slow down and kind of
see what's going on
so that's the kind of cool thing about
superhot - in VR is you can take it at
your own speed so if you need to like oh
man I need a breather there's like four
guys around me just standing still and
kind of be like yo this is a thing broke
anything else yet yeah it's just tase a
casualty and the monitors motors lookin
fine though I got him okay now here it's
next-level think I'm ready to go my hair
is a mess
yes the the controller's of chastity is
using right now come with the rift right
now most of the bundles you can get are
they include the rift headset the two
the two hand controllers an Xbox 360
controller with the wireless dongle and
like two sensors you can do a 3 sensor
setup which makes tracking a lot more
accurate but to works fine I finally
stopped sweating I'm pretty normal right
so that's the cool thing about being in
the yards that for so long as soon as
you like get out of the VR headset the
regular studio lights so thank you to
Eric and Richard what's your worst
breakage playing VR games I one time
actually punched one of my monitors so
that it put I think that was when I was
playing sound boxing so I was just
getting really into it that's there for
us just being with the types of things I
can get that one apology I'll do so come
with Xbox game pads I know they come
with the two sensors I recommend yeah
three is recommended for room scale the
one that I got not too long ago still
came with the 360 controller that is
tough it's it's it's a challenging home
it's low but also
Oh schoolboy Dodgers all right
hey Paradise how you doing welcome to
the show hope you're having a wonderful
it's Thursday right Thursday it's it's
not a joke
Georgie I'm about to purchase this steam
as a special the original price is $199
it's sixteen dollars for five VR games
that's probably check it out a bit - are
the goggles heavier fit weird actually
think the oculus that's pretty comfy
yeah I like the oculus headset I just I
either have too small the head I don't
know I'm moving around a lot the other
problem is we went from my big dumb head
we switched out really quickly I'm doing
just fine yeah it's got a lot of
adjustable straps and also I like that
it comes with its own headphones yes you
don't have to like have a headset on or
anything oh yeah and you can also get a
lot of there's a lot of modular parts on
it so you can get like different face
face rings so you get those kind of
sweet aftermarket parts
oh good feels good man
feels good all right where we hey it's
you again hey Cody you're real close do
you know about boundaries you know
personal space gray fox says work calls
gotta run thanks for your stream band
chesty happy holidays everyone happy
holidays to you as well you know I think
that might be where I actually bought my
my face protective I grabbed your leg
now that we cool what's that when did
you get on it at 12:00
yeah it was like 12:05 okay so it's at
12:27 you're you're you're cruising yeah
we've got a little bit of this and we'll
switch to rural recall offer it to you
do you want to recall cuz you're doing
this side I thought I'd offer it you
look like you're in the zone I'm never
out of the zone and that's the secret to
my success five minutes one that's true
the others
your headset stimulated a distance
screen that's a very good thing to bring
up it's actually interesting as a person
who wears glasses I have to have glasses
that fit inside of an actual head so
yeah so I have to use old glasses from
high school that when my face was
smaller so they can they could fit
inside of it because if you have really
bad eyesight like me the fact that it's
emulating actually seeing things far off
it actually looks like it's really
blurry can't see the helicopter with the
VR I submit all three of the games we're
playing today sound boxing as well beat
saber the good thing about the one we're
about to play Roman recall is it comes
free with there's some really good
physics I needed that no surprise that
Resident Evil 7 still hasn't been made
VR on PC yet but oculus and I guess
would be fun still feeling all right
it's it's been almost feels good heck
yeah it's any time I play sprint vector
I can only do it for like 30 or 45
minutes before I feel like I'm gonna die
but really really rad it's like a VR
freerunning
Jet Set Radio future game highly
recommend it great soundtrack really
cool like design my hair is in my mouth
I hate having long hair yeah robo recall
is I know for a fact it's with the touch
controllers well it's not gonna happen
wait for it wait for what story's gotta
happen this exposition okay all right Oh
Mike you gotta like yo dance it out oh
snap back to reality oh yeah it is 1231
all right we did it you feel it I feel
good all right I can't wait for you to
see how pretty I look that's it looks
like you didn't even put on a headset
you're fine all right I'm gonna get up
here in a second Knowles what switch the
game over uh hi everyone oh it's me I'm
the screen chassis is on our way so I
can go proud of your headset don't go
anywhere
what's up y'all no don't move now
welcome to our VR lives room if you're
just joining us I'm a sweaty lady and my
name is chesty and I just played the
super hot VR and I'm badass John wick
like assassin who doesn't cry when she
runs away from a bullet and we're
playing the next game which is Robo
recall Ben's gonna get into virtual
reality sorry if it's a little sweaty in
there I got really heated it happens and
I have long hair which I probably should
have put up before I became a spy but I
wanted to look good as
spy and that's my problem vanity it'll
bring you down anyway we're in the chat
youtube.com slash GameSpot let's talk
about VRS up at superhot let's talk
about being a cool badass by all rights
and all this is presented by oculus
today and that's why we're playing three
oculus games so we have one more left
we're playing all the way until 1 p.m.
Pacific time so Ben is gonna play Robo
recall which I love this is a really fun
game
how much robo recall have you played
been probably the VR game might have
played the most Marty back in we're good
all rights to the library start up Robo
Rico mmm-hmm water cool alright yeah
we're in the chat so just holler at me
about superhot and rope recall and any
other VR games that you enjoy alright
are we ready to play yeah we resume
playing to come back in and do something
with the game maybe for fullscreen but
okay we're gonna do the game really
quick so let's see how the chats doing
paradise ed Borderlands 2 VR is superb
nice I haven't played that yet see much
like these robots we are a well-oiled
machine we got this long sides to launch
yep yep
yeah kinda here was talking about
resident evil 7br yeah
every time that was a scary game to play
in VR
oh yeah it says right there on the on
the well you guys probably can't see how
because I'm like see what you're looking
at it says free with oculus touch so
robo recall comes with yeah controllers
Sufi you haven't jumped on the oculus
train yet you can get robo recall with
your oculus that's really cool
because I really like that game it's a
lot of fun so in Robo recall you're just
shooting a bunch of robots but it you
can also tear them apart use different
guns it's a lot of fun star we starting
out a new save or save kind of story
but is that what was just from playing
yesterday I got 80% of the way through
it but it's really important there's
there's good exposition and plot that
happens so alright it is our last game
of the day too so it's good to kind of
take it all in yeah there's some robots
and the robots are gonna go bad they're
an attack you
spoilers sorry Bob Jones said chassis
glad to keep taking a break from dodging
bullets yes I am because my legs are
sore from dance class and that was
really difficult but I had fun I had a
good John wick time in VR I would play
again there was some mention of beat
saber I would love to play beat more
beats a bio evade a very short amount of
heat saber and I can't wait to play
pannier said Robo recalls a web shooter
you'll get hot and sweaty oh yeah yes
what is happening the robots are going
nuts sounds like they might need to
recall these robots you might need to
recall them that's what's happening here
oh no they've been hacked this moment's
really good because I've never felt more
uncomfortable in a virtual reality Oh
God we all just jump eeeh
but it's okay though cuz we're gonna
bring the pain there it is
got cool cool guns coming up we've got
cool cool throwing things around ripping
robots to the left the other way my lips
are your less there you go good tiny
baby steps okay now you good actually
the notary said this looks cool it is
this is very cool so now we're in the
office to the office to get some
training let's gonna do this really fast
boom sorry centered my stuff's now I
know where I'm standing
mm-hmm into the office we go teleport
whoo the basics let's go practice some
shooting gotta learn about grabbing and
about ripping and tearing here we go get
to go onto that pad or just wait for the
tutorial thing to be like do this
training tutorial eyes so I grab this
you got a boy here he's magnetically
attached to that and then slap him
around with his own hands
yourself slapping such a violent act and
just what I love when games
VR games have like really cool just like
spaces for you to do things in like I
can just grab this cup and like toss it
over there that's Robo Rico a basketball
game get it in there oh god it's - oh
wow
just flew all over the place don't know
my own strength physics man here we go
those are just hands here come the guns
alright this is a really important thing
about this game that feels really good
is just how you like you'll you'll shoot
all the bullets out yeah then you don't
actually reload you just toss them away
and then you can grab more from your
side nice you can kind of like cool I
don't know how many but we're catching
other guns alright so we're gonna do our
first level here let's do it
jump in take me in that's where I want
to go product alert yeah if your guns
ready it's about to go down
Oh the first tip and it tells me is my
favorite thing you can reload your gun
by bouncing off of an enemy nice zero
points well we'll get there we'll get
something mission start Robo recruit
let's go I'm ready ready also like kind
of the arcade approach that we take to
this game yet which is kind of cool you
guys can see it but I can't my my score
collect chips to increase your
multiplier alright
still getting tutorial eyes multiplier
on our way
[Music]
agent more crawlers
I'm not very good at shooting my weapon
but yeah hey Jeff oh hello do you
transport yourself around yeah
the robots are coming at you rip one
apart apart oh man hold on Wow so you
can grab bullets out of the air to
return to sender
whoo if you guys are just tuning in
we're playing a robo recall on the
oculus rift and this is games about live
presented by oculus today we previously
played superhot just before this and
before that I expect you to die but yeah
these are some fun games and this game
comes with so you should definitely
check it out
yeah I highly recommend it you also get
it free with your hand hand bits hand
pits
I guess such yeah the oculus touch
grab that revolver oh you can also get
like different attachments and upgrade
your guns yeah
so that's really exciting their shotguns
turret yeah yeah those are good hello oh
I've got my back holsters that's what I
was looking for rip them apart I had to
reach out a bit to get Phillip I am it
is an older erotic model scheduled for
shutdown she seems alright what's next
where are the robots at they're they're
coming we're getting some exposition
right now please recall as many as you
can
we call teto months you can yeah you got
15 minutes to wreck robots
oh come on YouTube GameSpot if you have
any questions or want to talk about VR
oh Emily extra point there you go
was a two-for-one
you're wrecking shop these are not-- I'm
very proud of you
I hate these buggers you me get rid of
all of them
they're terrible Oh No oh that's so cool
oh I hate when they fly at you is there
anything you can do for your health and
escape this comes back if you don't get
shot a shield yeah yeah
cool 29 that's not bad it's not bad at
all they ask you for 10 cool you're a
beast man I'm feeling it
yeah do you feel like a badass I feel
like those guys man you're outnumbered
complete so this is the intro I like
this game a lot yeah
cool good game good game we've got about
15 minutes now your teen or so minutes
left in our stream back to the office
on to the next level all right it's good
just go right back still the same stuff
here in the office there isn't really
much semester it's changed it did you
get any upgrades or no I think that's
what you do in here I know it's about to
teach me what upgrades who crime said
wishing you an amazing holidays love you
all looking forward to seeing you 2019
oh thanks crime Thank You crime
thanks for hanging out with us no I'm
good but you get the laser sight
securely cuts those laser sights very
helpful especially at the beginning yeah
put that back on there it's not gonna
actually kind of just whipping around
without having to worry about hitting
stuff I can I can hipfire is yeah feel
better about it it's cool I like it
Bob Jones said what's the best VR game
you two have played it's actually this
revelry is my favorite my favorite game
I want to play more beat saver as well
beat saver definitely I also want to
play more of I keep talking outside
boxing really really like sound box it's
very cheap it's very good it's very
versatile super hot I also recommend I
just played that rights
clear path the collection area what's
doing let's go go oh you don't Blazer
say I forgot to accept the upgrade oh
man that's all right you know you don't
even need it
badasses don't even get joint oops
with my gun oops
like teleporting behind them and just
like ripping them up yeah there's so
many robots those clothes how about you
guys in the chat what's your favorite VR
game ever
I'd be interested to hear we talked
about ours and said robo recall much
sloth monkey said won't let go
that was good Aloha it was a pretty good
time Elsa like how I 28,000 whines look
at you yeah I'm feeling it I like how in
VR games like if you actually like use
the site's for a gun it actually helps
which is really wild and a lot of games
don't do but it's nice yeah
crime said this game should be called
Elon Musk nightmare
that works think so good looking out
behind you
thank you are you doing always flying in
the air
double juggle
oh all right I don't like those shining
lights in your face it's just feels so
good to play all right 1519 seems too
bad I'm gonna take shotgun with me we
did like 28 or 29 when they asked you
for 10 you can do this oh I thought
you're gonna keep going Wow nice
ah here Christ keep talking nobody
exposes my favorite because I can play
without getting sick that's a good game
that's fun to play with your friends
there are a lot of really good VR games
that you don't get sick while you play
it is nice because not everyone has the
same level of being able to put up with
it look yellow yellow probably play the
most so I know like a lot of this stuff
for anything but you know how it works
[Music]
how they do that that's what I hate
ah hello got it
their spores racking up
[Laughter]
it's the dumb stuff to kind of make it
work you know but stuff here right my
right yeah here we go yeah you're good
awesome I'm feeling it six minutes left
in this dream yeah we're doing it we're
doing it I think we're about to actually
get to a boss fight oh yeah let's end on
a boss fight that's a good place to end
the stream who are you it's like one of
those that bullet oh it's actually like
a B because it was a shotguns for you
it's walking up like nothing's going on
I guess yeah
ah that's not my gun oh we can throw it
good job want that yeah you do there we
go
girl wants that have you guys tried
hell-blade in the arts incredible I use
one as a shield lily boys get behind him
surprise attack I think we're good
he did to brought back something yeah
where's the boss I think it's coming up
yeah I think he lands right in the
middle there huh that might be him up
there that seems like
let's at least ten bucks oh you're just
gonna throw the bots in the middle right
there's a tornado here yeah throw them
in the tornado
I don't need my guns then I need to tell
more behind him come here hold them back
and talk
yeah we're recalling them you know yeah
this is a little literal part of the
game where we're recalling these robots
into the tornado Oh get in there just
didn't want to do it I guess Toby
good nailed it yeah geez that's so many
bullets you can't toss the castle you're
right there am i doing she's going we
have three more three more
oh there you are that's the last one he
needs to go hey hey it's time to go come
with me
so did you really hold him in upward Oh
excellent
there he goes we did it yeah you nailed
it
oh there are bullets right in my face is
this time yeah I believe so
yeah I think it's easier to just
Jah
it works take it
what's shooting oh these guys we did it
you did it oh you get out of here like
it whoo good score
thank you two hundred and seventy-six
thousand five hundred and nine thousand
my bad
I'll take it I just shut up it's x all
right you may exit the game yeah 159
yeah we're at but there's so many more
like there's so much VR well thank you
thanks so much for watching and thank
you to oculus for letting us play all
these awesome games on the oculus rift
today so this was presented by oculus we
played a bunch of fun games I can see
you wave to the [ __ ]
wave to the fine people thank you
there's Ben Ben says goodbye everyone
who's gonna stay in virtual reality
yeah I'm standing here the rest of the
day it's a place to be you can't take me
out of here I mean yeah alright well
thank you guys for watching we'll see
you next time again spot left
you